okay we've heard this a while ago so you
can tell me that if you have a sum a
plus B and you swear the whole thing
what's our expansion okay so texts for
right now this is not on the reference
sheet parlor because it is so easy to
learn however it's been a while since we
use this hardware is so simple we often
don't worry about it so this is the kind
of place where see them ever mistakes
really creep in okay
bit of an aside you're interested in
which you're going to sit next to a BA
in mathematics it's composed of two
well-defined sections okay there's
questions 1 to 10 does anyone know they
don't have an older sibling who knows
what questions 1 to 10 are questions 1
to 10 are multiple choice okay so ABCD
ABCD etc then you get in the remainder
of 3 hours question 11 question 12 13
all the way to 16 okay the easiest
question is in the paper are right there
in question 11 I'll explain why in a
minute it's not question 1 to 10 maybe a
bit later on but question 11 in the HSC
has questions like this and people get
12 17 and 18 year old students who've
been seeing these things for years still
get them wrong
it's just to me why how on earth people
like us could mess up something so
simple any thoughts yeah
okay number one everything you are oh
this is a chassis it looks easy I must
be doing something wrong okay that
happens yes good other reasons this is
quite early in the paper does anyone
ever had that experience where you're
doing stuffing one of you're like man
what was I thinking when I did that well
you probably weren't thinking because
your brain is just got me started right
so you have it warmed up so you make
lots of silly errors in there
the most common error for this is when
people say that it's a squared plus B
squared it's a pretty easy mistake to
make right how would you prove to
someone that they're wrong that it's not
okay well I'm gonna I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be little Johnny confused here for
you right now I'm gonna say but I did
extend it that's the expansion expansion
means get rid the brackets there
brackets I'm done okay so he's another
way I could do it I could say this right
are you happy with that
okay to which my response is yeah yeah
but nice that's a squared and I told you
what's okay come on you're wasting my
time here does someone want to give you
better suggestion
oh yeah that's fine that's fine
there's a nice being squared and a big
being squared and you're adding them
right come on guys really isn't that it
hmm
okay now these are not all bad
suggestions he's fine they often would
work if little Johnny confusable is so
confused okay his middle name is very
here's what I would suggest instead
there was clearly a problem here
wasn't there what was the problem what
did I do wrong what should I done yeah
more like I can't just pause they're
absolutely correct
do you realize how hard this is what
we're doing right and you're gonna have
to do it things that you think you know
I actually would contend that most of us
don't know we have just practiced really
hard and so we're quite good at reciting
but your extension students now it's not
gonna cut it okay see these things here
right on the extension side it's not
gonna be enough just have a look at that
top right hand corner just have a look
at that for a second okay I know at the
moment also I thought took them back
then like there's the remaining that
says acceleration okay and then there
are five expressions that all look like
algebra and they all apparently our
acceleration okay now if all you got is
what you have right now yeah but this is
the way I've done it in those previous
questions and you can actually explain
and get past here we're gonna be in
trouble
okay I think the word we're looking for
here you might want to like this is the
distributive law does that word ring
about that phrase ring a bell the
distributive law when you take something
and you multiply it across brackets you
don't just pick and choose you
distribute right so you're multiplying
everything in here by a and everything
in here by B does that make sense that's
where there's two abs come on okay can I
give you one more illustration I need
you to control this for me get a ruler
out draw for me I swear
make a decent size I haven't said
anything about diagrams yet because this
is something our second lesson so let's
say it right now the smallest diagram
you should draw should be about the size
of your pom-pom right hand with your
palm okay you may have a small pump
that's that's okay
I guess that means that you probably be
shorter and closer to the page so
relatively I don't know anyway
palm size minimum okay and usually like
when we're doing graphic you guys are
done graphing for a couple of years for
sure sometimes those take up like a
third of the page so if you're gonna
mess with it we're going to turn this
square into this square yeah like that's
what we call it square no one reads that
as ^ - and there's a reason why it's cuz
now it's our a plus B squared okay so if
I'm trying to translate this thing into
this thing what's the site level it's a
site like this where a plus B I don't
know what it must be
I ain't beyond so I'm just gonna make
some random division like that let's
just call that side a and that side bein
we can move it around if we like these
can be very if that's a plus B that
means I'm a maple speed going down here
as well don't I'm so let's see how well
I didn't you've got a rule on so
but if it's a square there's a plus B
there's all that also a plus B and just
going to pause from brief moment one of
these are going to have to get used to
in this class is being uncomfortable
being comfortable is you get given a
question and then I give you the answer
straight away that's comfortable it's
comfortable but you don't learn very
much when I do a document I want you to
look at this diagram for a second you
gave me some explanations for why these
are untrue I want you to think if you
have this diagram what could you do to
explain this sending a bit louder I
could divide this square right I will
divide this square because just like
this has geometric minis here Alex I
think this has geometric meanings too
can you see where a squared is can you
see it it's not there yet but you see
where should I draw some lines
they're there you know in the place with
the spot that the guy and that stuff
have to be precise in mathematical
language really matters how about a
vertical line where would you like me to
place it how about on my dividing line
but my white spot between a and B okay
so now it can be some language written
for the other line and what kind of like
will it be it should be a horizontal
line and I'm gonna do the same thing is
that enough of an argument is that
convincing I think it's pretty
convincing for us now having spent the
last 10 minutes thinking about it but
you're your friend Johnny confused needs
a little more nudging what could you add
to this to make it absolutely watertight
suggestions
surely the two dates that are they we're
always very happy people to maybe yeah
yeah good
wait where is a sweat well you told me
you could see it was here but there's a
square must be square there is right
here diet making you diagonally across
so this B squared
so what's that typo this is a B and this
are you convinced now okay mathematics
we call this proof proof really matters
you're gonna be doing a heck of a lot of
it okay this is the first result if
you've already download the textbook
miss southern view of mission you can
see they also talk about not just the
square root son but the square of a
difference and also the difference of
squares which I reflects you on the on
the reference sheet I wouldn't force you
to do this but if you're interested if
you have to make an argument like this
for these guys
I wonder how you would use just a bit of
a challenge
okay